the interesting thing about vanning was
specific the bands are supposed to
reduce recreation use we're not sure
they do they start people perhaps
talking about it but they don't stop
recreation is but what they do do is
they stop research we know that someone
who takes our SD as brain damage he can
become insane I'm from the discovery of
LSD in 1943 to it being banned in 1967
there were 140 NIH grants in America to
study LSD 140 grams a thousand papers
were published 40,000 patients were
studied since the drug was made illegal
in 1967 there has not been a single
study of LSD in America Russian Roulette
with a sugar cube now that's that's
Karenina dead why would you not want to
study these drugs which produce profound
changes in consciousness how can you
study consciousness without perturbing
it
and the research opportunities lost by
banning these drugs are vast because the
therapeutic potential of these drugs
like cannabis and psychedelics is
enormous we have talked about the
potential of psychedelics to treat
addictions and depression and anxiety
etc and of course there's a whole range
of other disorders it drugs like
cannabis could be potentially useful for
so the reality is in most of the world
these drugs are still illegal and almost
no research into the gun
[Music]
[Music]